[Music]
teams wins what makes this game great
teams win
don't write the end of the story yet
don't write the end of the story yet
story's just starting man
it's not the end of the story yet
everybody everybody's going to write the
end of the story but i'm telling you the
story's not over yet
i'd say go ahead and write the end of
the story we'll change the ending right
lock in your narrative write us off
assume we're going to stink please
chargers titans raiders falcons i think
we're not going to be any good it plays
right into their hands it does yeah now
vegas vegas has already written the
the story in a different way chris from
caesars the nfl's official gaming
partner odds to win the super bowl went
from 15 to one to 40 to one yeah for the
indianapolis right not a surprise not a
surprise 2019 win total over underwent
from 10 all the way down to seven
from plus 210 to plus 325 to win the afc
south meaning if you wager 100 you now
win 325 versus 210 if they win the afc
south and week one it went from when
they faced the chargers in la they are
now seven point underdogs they were
three point underdogs previously so yeah
we've seen the needle move and it's
going to stay in that direction until
they prove they can win with jacobi
perception yeah exactly right jacoby
brissett's going to have to prove
himself the teams that have to prove
that they can win without andrew luck
which i think they can do i mean i'm not
going to sit here and go oh gosh there's
no way they can win at the los angeles
chargers in week one baloney they
certainly can i mean like we talked
about a little earlier this team has
still got a ton of talent plus the
people in that room who have experience
with these type of situations not only
has frank reich been in this situation
personally himself when he was a backup
quarterback okay you mentioned the
carson wentz situation and nick foles so
he he can put himself in the shoes to go
if i was a new quarterback in this
situation what would i want done to help
me get going on an offense a little bit
make me feel good and then added to that
uh yes he also knows just from a play
call play designer standpoint what it
takes a little because of what he did
with nick foles so i think there's a lot
of positives here about
the formula they have and they don't
need jacoby brissett to go out and throw
for 350 yards every game they can do it
a lot of different ways apart from teams
that are on their schedule early that
will be playing them and now thinking
they have an easier win big picture the
teams in the afc that benefit the most
from luck being gone and i think we have
to start with the other teams in the afc
south definitely they have to be popping
the champagne over this one right i
think so and you know again the afc
south houston's a little i mean just
from pre-season football and i know it's
pre-season football but it hasn't looked
stellar coming out of there okay uh the
tennessee titans haven't looked stellar
either when you look at what they've
done in the preseason you know so you
know yes the afc south certainly gonna
feel like oh that's one less obstacle
out of our way but i also think of like
the cleveland browns now you go ooh
maybe three teams in the afc north can
make it the ravens the steelers the
baltic you know uh and the cleveland
browns you look out to the west you know
and it makes it maybe a more clear path
for the chargers and the chiefs i mean
there's just a little less competition
just to open the door for the two teams
we're in love with that we say could be
a pain in the butt for everybody the
bills and the jets they're looking at it
going oh okay i like this you know so we
firmly believe one of those two teams
will be in the mix very much
right so i i mean it really is
fascinating what's done to the afc and
the patriots have less to worry about if
they encounter the indianapolis colts at
some point remember the rivalry's back
on that was it
from chris ballard right after josh
mcdaniels bailed on the colts but yeah
look i i think that
the smart reaction
will be the bill belichick reaction it
doesn't matter yes it just doesn't
matter we still have to play the cults
when we have to play the cults whichever
opponent you can't look
less
of the cults and think less of the cults
with andrew luck gone or they will beat
you yeah they're capable of beating you
if you take them lightly and team it's
team like chris ballard said and the a
team is what makes the uh you know an
organization go i know we all want to go
quarter at quarter at quarterback
quarterback but i know i lived it with
my father in the new york giants he got
hurt and they were you know 12 and two
and they went on to win the super bowl
oh sorry dad you're not the greatest
thing since sliced bread same thing with
carson wentz oh sorry you're not the
greatest thing since sliced bread it's
about the team you know even with new
england up there brady's like you said
the greatest of all time they're 14-6
without him i mean so you know why
because the team and the coaching staff
around him is really good too and i will
not be surprised with all the players
that chris ballard has
put forth on this team along with the
coaching on the defense and offensive
side of the ball to where uh there's
plenty to go around and it's not going
to just have to be jacoby brissett
they'll expand the screen game they'll
expand their running game a little bit
to take pressure off of them early uh
and and i think they're fully capable of
doing that i don't know that the fans
feel the same way you know i haven't
really talked about this in detail there
was a lot of hand wringing and finger
wagging at colts fans who booed on
saturday night as andrew luck was
leaving the field
and and yeah it's a bad look it's bad
form right but when you're in the
perspective
of a colts fan who's at a game that
means nothing that's right none of the
starters are playing right and you're
there because you know in large part you
have to buy the full price preseason
tickets in order to get the full price
regular season tickets and you're
getting ready for a season of promise
where they're leading you believe he's
going to be good to go you've got jim
irsay saying this is the best team since
the days of peyton manning and then you
look down at your phone
and you see that the andrew luck's
retiring you're dismayed and look the
the range of options available to a fan
in the stands in the game it's cheer or
boo right i know in europe they whistle
yeah but it's cheer or boo so i mean
what do you do i mean i i feel like
you've had the entire season from under
you and it's not like you're getting a
refund on all those tickets you bought
that you may not have bought if someone
had bothered to tell you that andrew
luck wasn't going to play no i i hear
you and and again it's nfl i mean it's
nfl football it's professional sports in
america right now yes i think you know
as cooler heads of prevail or maybe some
of those people that booed him in the
stadium it's not necessarily like booing
him i think they appreciate it the
situation
exactly right that's where i kind of
looked at it too it's messed up that it
got announced or leaked before the game
was ended and that's another subject we
should get into at some point to where
that came from maybe that benefited yes
i mean there's a lot that to that story
there but i do i'm with you mike i think
it's more of like damn i thought we were
going to win the super bowl this year or
at least be in super bowl contention you
know like boo now we're screwed so i
don't think it was necessarily personal
but certainly not a great look for the
colts and their fans uh sending them out
that yeah for plenty of stories like
this there's speculation as to who
leaked it but this one definitely
definitely i mean this was all going to
be announced to the world at 3 p.m
eastern on sunday
and the goal was to keep it under the
wraps until then and somebody decided
we're going to let this out during a
home game right right i mean
and yeah we're going to do that later in
the program i got some thoughts on that
there's some things i've heard about
that which makes some sense but uh
definitely andrew luck's hand got forced
and got put in a tough situation where
the fans were assembled looked at their
phones and found out i mean i'd be
wondering why that why is he even here
if you're retiring why are you even here
go home i don't well it's like one of
those things where it looks like they
wanted to go let's let the game play out
and not be a distraction and then maybe
i don't just from the outside looking in
at some point did somebody in the
organization say you know what i don't
want this to drag on let's just get it
done right now i don't know if that
happened or it's just the fact that too
many people throughout league circles
had known the rumor and what was going
on and maybe like we've said this was
percolating certainly before monday of
this past week i'm just again franchise
quarterbacks who have made are on 100
million dollar contracts they don't walk
into the office on monday and go you
know
i've been thinking my ankle's sore and i
think i'm retiring no this was something
that is obviously in his brain and i
think that i think colts and some of
their comments especially like we talked
about with jim irsay kind of let it slip
between the cracks there that this has
been something going on and uh that this
is something andrew lee
don't make a decision until the last
possibility which is the last possible
moment right is after the third
preseason game because that's when the
preparations commence in earnest for
week one yeah so we need to know who our
quarterback is after the third preseason
game when you look back at frank reich's
quote from a free a few weeks ago where
he says we got to know after the third
preseason game when you read that now
knowing what we know now yeah psych wait
a minute
because at the time it's like well this
is weird because
andrew luck's not practicing he's not
going to play in the preseason
it happened after the third pre-season
game who the starters he's not playing
in the preseason so why would it be him
yeah with the benefit now of knowing
what we know i think
i think that they whether it was march
whether it was april may june whatever
they knew about it and at some point
they had the conversation
when do we have to make a final decision
right we have to make a final decision
by the third preseason game we have to
know by then because after that the ship
sails and you're either on it or you're
not so and and and i'm i just wonder and
i'm throwing stuff out there again you
know i just wonder okay he was dealing
with the calf injury okay and maybe this
was all going on in his brain already
and he'd already kind of let the cat out
of the back of the organization then
does the ankle injury happen and that's
finally where he goes okay
i i'm pushed over the top here you know
that was the same injury i know is it
the same injury i don't know these are
things that i hope will get flushed out
here over the next few weeks did it
cross your mind at all yes we got to
take a break but did it cross your mind
at all that maybe he wasn't injured the
entire 100 percent first thing that
crossed my mind i said that's just cover
this has always been like sorted out
let's just sort it out and see how you
feel as time goes on we don't need you
out there on the football field take a
break get away from the game a little we
want you to run the building but you
have to go through the grind on a
day-to-day basis see how that makes you
feel yeah that's to me what it looks
like we get jacobi percent ready that
and then and it was two injuries where
you can't really tell if you're oh the
calf muscle he's walking around fine oh
yeah you know calf muscles they're
they're they're you got to watch out for
them it's when you move and do something
you know so there were two injuries that
you know you can't really like quantify
just looking at and look you know and
say oh he's hurt i i'm not saying no i
don't know that seems that way but i
think it was a reasonable reaction yes
while we process all this was that
really an injury or was it an effort to
give him maximum time to make his father
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports